-Finally,
as I mentioned earlier,
a 28-year-old Latina woman
named Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
who has never held
public office,
beat the 10-term incumbent
Joe Crowley
at New York's Democratic
congressional primary.
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Jenny Hagel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth.
This is so exciting.
Ocasio-Cortez is Puerto Rican,
and I am, too,
so in the spirit
of Latina women getting it done,
I have a little message for her.
Would it be okay
if I said it in Spanish?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, Of course,
or, por favor.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Sí.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, Seth...
[ Speaking Spanish ]
-[ Laughing ]
Okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Seth.
-All right, yeah!
Give it up for Jenny over there!
Keep an eye on her.
I think she's going places.